holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know oh baby we're all over the place
timonium maryland magooby's august 26th
couple of crabs and we're going to tejas
baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd will be in houston
texas september 23rd through the 25th
austin texas for the moon tower comedy
festival and i ain't done yet august
26th will be at fort dallas fort worth
texas what then we're bringing it back
to long island baby what in all uh
september 30th and then we're coming
home the boys are the chickens are
coming home to roost baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skankfest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or
trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grow
up to be classy or if they're just a big
old piece of trash i'm your host age
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at aunt tooty's basement
she's very excited about our guest that
we have uh here with us today back with
us today she wants him to take a 23andme
test because she thinks that the
families are related really but i think
she's just angling for some property
back in the old
yeah yeah she wants to have a place to
bring people if she goes over to ireland
she could be a lady could a lord and a
lady absolutely dame aunt tooty however
it works i like it my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he's the
ceo of ru garbage he's an international
businessman and he is not to be trifled
with or
taken lightly sure he's kind of the head
bozo around here so do me a favor make
me look good show him a little respect
give it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
through the [ __ ] roof cookie
and then
i mean
everybody knows
patreon.com when i say [ __ ] cooking
that thing i mean that's like
that's like a viking stove over there
that's expected businessman at this
point we just passed 21 over 2100
patrons we love a whole bunch of money
every month thank you so [ __ ] much we
keep that number semi-private by the way
uh guys thank you so much we [ __ ]
appreciate you guys to get bonus
episodes of ayg episodes of hard
feelings live streams you get first dibs
on merch the whole [ __ ] nine yards
the whole shebang and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he makes us
all look good
i'm talking about a good kid started at
the chicago comedy scene recent new york
transplant taken over the [ __ ] comedy
scene here in new york give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up
dudes what up t-bone nothing i'm excited
dude we got some energy in the this
this dude is the conor mcgregor of
comedy he talks hell is [ __ ]
he'll fight a booker i'm excited before
he gets started this guy's bonkers
this guy is pure i say that about a lot
of people that come in here this guy's
bonko's and i love the [ __ ] out of him
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest back
with us again today if you haven't
listened to his episode go back and
check it out everybody loves him
everybody wanted him on the show we love
him we're so excited to have him here i
believe these quarters are saying that
american kids are spoiled lazy
is that what you said about us you [ __ ]
sucker
he's the host of the wizard of pot give
it up for the one the only counter out
yes what's up what's up buddy i thought
it's it's celery feels dead
[Laughter]
it's so awkward why when people like
build the big the big interest it's just
like oh [ __ ] i know how are we are we
doing it i know and i feel we should do
that you deserve that oh thank you i
appreciate it but it's like it's like
you're like [ __ ] no [ __ ] i got to come
up with something here
in
i don't know what to do yeah and he said
i'm like conor mcgregor's because i i
punch old man
[Laughter]
his bones easy yeah yeah i have a limp
he's got osteoporosis now connor will be
back yeah connor we love you
can he fight again can you fight after
injury like that i don't mind
come on he came in a sweaty long sleeve
t-shirt what the [ __ ] does he do i know
where were you looking you went swimming
in that i was i was stuck on the train
man yeah oh the train forget about it
yeah no on way
uh in that car it was but it wasn't good
enough not good
sometimes i'm getting to one of those
and it's like [ __ ] paradise yeah
sometimes you get in and yeah oh it's
like the arctic or something though
you're freezing no way to catch a fever
though in the summer going in and out of
that [ __ ] a little bit of kovid just
catch a little bit of delta a little bit
of delta there's a lambda virus or
variant too i heard about so what yeah a
new one lambda lambda yeah now this is
like people naming stars
[Laughter]
is that the orion's belt variant i see i
got the judy variant yeah yeah jimmy's
covered
sounds like an irish bar yeah come on
down to jimmy skovat everybody buddy how
have you been god's going great you're
doing great pod's doing okay yeah
i'm not man that's the most irish you
are so [ __ ] irish i'm not listen this
time last year i'd be delighted with my
is exactly that's what you said but but
it's still lose our numbers
are you garbage taking over the game
stop it taking over the game youtube i
do i brought a present can i give it to
you yeah please yes oh i forgot i forgot
about this already this is for aunt
actually oh i love it i brought a little
gift maybe for the basement i thought
you might like it
i don't know if there's anything more
trashy this than than an irish blessing
yes there's about nine in my mom's house
oh yeah so it was the irish blessing it
said
do you know it by heart no i never heard
of it until i came to this country
i swear yeah you don't know that one
never heard of him told us that they
told us that the night when he went to
bed no someone made that up on one of
the coffin ships on the way over here he
was bored in ellis island
wrote it on the back of it how can i rip
these rubes off when i get there
i suppose those don't know what's going
on yeah
let's say it's may uh an old irish
blessing may the road rise to meet you
may the wind always be at your back may
the sunshine warm upon your face and the
rainfall
soft on your fields
and until we meet again
may
god hold you in the hollow hollow of his
hand there you go get a couple of
[ __ ] shots after that damn that's it
so i think it sits on a little has a
little yeah it's a little plate in there
like it's a commemorative place it's our
first commemorative plate now let me who
did you steal that from i've been
dreaming for people to bring a [ __ ] like
this oh yeah fired up hell yeah yeah no
i didn't
i bought that on amazon it's all roughed
up you bought it for us well let's be
honest i bought a few months ago thought
i'd be back sooner
it's a little dusty
i told you i guess i told you he had b
for this sorry annie letterman was in
town
i told you he had beef about this yeah
because when we had that when we had to
reschedule the one time no no because of
an emergency
i said i will we'll make sure we get you
soon that's what you said last time
i was joking around josh but no do you
know what did happen that time
and this is this is very funny i never
told didn't you reschedule at one point
no no absolutely no i've got i've got no
i was here i've got eight o'clock in the
morning um well you t i was driving my
truck one day
because i drive trucks for a living
dragon and i know not mine it was a
rental
i get i get it i get a um
i got a text from
uh foley over here and and i just i was
like my phone's in between my legs and i
was like hey
you want to swing by
um are you garbage tonight or something
like this it's like yeah i can i can
make it work whatever so i run home i
drive home i've got i drop the truck
back i get changed i can't come flying
in and i show up at the door and then
there's there's no one here and i was
like what the hell what now but listen
then i look at the text again it turns
out you said tomorrow or not tonight and
i had miss rabbit
i went down were you at the door right
now at the door scratching like a dog
there was a little box for there was a
little box for kevin oh you were made
into this
like in the building i got to talk to
security i would love to do that and
then i went through i never and i i
never even texted and i went home and
then and then the next day i was like oh
yeah we have to cancel anyway
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] don't mind listen i got
nothing how long did you wait at that
door knocking i need no it's the second
you guys
i went to texas you can tell the lights
aren't on too yeah i knew there was no
one here
i could still think you thinking that
we're in here playing a trick on you're
[ __ ] pounding that is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] come out a huge phobia of mine
is to have like someone organized
for me and then i arrive and there's no
one there and then i get a text and
we're like ah yes
i know what we're doing next time
wait that's what your phobias yeah
listen to this when i was in high school
a friend of mine um it was his birthday
and he organized a toga party all right
and he sends everyone like a facebook
group toga party at andy's everyone
arrive and then he texts everyone
individually and goes oh by the way it's
not a toga party it's a regular part oh
my god i'm pranking my friend uh ryan or
whatever so then
so
we all show up the party is advertised
for eight we all show up at seven mm-hmm
ryan shows up dressed in toga and we're
all not dressed in token he walks in
toga party
and he had to spend the entire night in
together i would've went home dude [ __ ]
that yeah he went home and changed and
came back yeah well he didn't
that was that's what my friend andy
wanted for his birthday was to embarrass
what an elaborate scheme dude that's
like
text to facebook
yeah and there was like a hidden
facebook group where it was like don't
tell don't say and everyone was like
commenting can't wait for toga just
bought my sheets and then
how do you guys feel about surprise
parties
i don't you think surprise parties are
trash
trash cause you're
you guys do them or they pop you guys
aren't like a [ __ ] surprise me bunch
over there
punched in the face
i've been to two
there was one for my mom
my ma
when she went 40 i think went 40. is
that not how you say turn turn and when
she turns short now she went she went
sounds like she passed away
well she went 92. she's gone she's 40.
that's it
any woman over the age of 30 is gone
but yes it was that and i remember they
kept their secret from me too because i
was like a young
i was like i think we might have talked
about this actually now that you bring
it up you'd run you're yeah you're a
little kid you're gonna tell him yeah
yeah especially your mom and then there
was could be a set up you don't know
yeah because they said they i remember
being so insulted but they were like i'd
go to my mom go hey mom do you like do
you like surprises and they're like
she's like yeah do you like birthday
parties oh my god what are you doing
saturday and then i walk away going yeah
yeah and then there was my cousin and
her and her husband had a huge fight
because like they went for a meal and
then on the way back you know the
husband was like hey let's let's pull
over to our rhymes you know oh that's
awesome i keep saying wrong because
everyone look at you
and they were in a fight but they were
and she was like no that i hate that pup
and she was like nah we good we'll just
go and have a quick point and she was
like absolutely not he's like that pub
sucks and he's like let's just let's
just go in for a minute she's like
listen i'm tired let's just go home and
he was like no
and then she's like it's my [ __ ]
birthday
and he was like well we're going in
shut the [ __ ] up
i've been playing this [ __ ] for months
and he's like dragging her in the door
and she's like and then she sees the
song she's like oh yeah
oh my god that's funny i had a i had a
girl [ __ ] great uh break up with me
rightly so um deserved it 100
broke up with me on my birthday at a
restaurant down in the the west village
all right shout out to cafe uh denico
right or was it dante cafe dante you
asked me like i was there you were there
in spirit um
but she had planned a surprise party
with all my friends at the bar i worked
at so we were going to the surprise
party afterwards and you didn't make it
through dinner to the party that's how
intolerable you are yeah yeah i mean she
made it through appetizers and was like
i have a whole night playing with this
[ __ ] idiot but i'm out of here but
she broke up with me before we went she
broke up with me because i kept i kept
doing the stupid thing of what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong tell me tell
me tell me
what was wrong
have you [ __ ] hung out with him for
an hour he's the worst thing in the
world dude
i love him to death but he stinks yeah
she was not a fan in the end i'll tell
you that um
broke up with me
i think it was during the appetizers i
had a bowl of mussels red in front of me
and i wouldn't order that as an entree
because i'm not a dirt bag um broke up
with me during the dinner
and then i was like hey by the way
there's a party up at martell's room
yeah
let's go we have to go we have to go up
there that went up there and did you
guys fake face it like walk around yeah
we faked facebook walked around and then
she softened towards the end of the
night and wanted to go home with me
after she got a couple of schlitzer's in
there right
one more one more run at the red dragon
yes
a parting gift you know what i mean
something for the spanx you know
yeah it's a tough look oh that's [ __ ]
great all right so gang as you know uh
when you sign up for
what what i do i don't know you got
dumped during the advertisers man
well after knowing him
i'm surprised well i'm surprised she
even made it through the appetizer and
also she organized such a beautiful gift
for you rang all your friends yeah the
two of them showed up
i like how you wedge them
that was a professional move right there
then they told me they didn't want to
see me anymore
yeah it was brutal and everybody knew
too because i walked in i got hit by a
buster like what's wrong i was like she
[ __ ] broke up with me
dude i would have left this girl right
there she's standing beside you that's
insane
that's wild yeah
so crazy yeah yeah i've heard of people
break up at the beginning of vacations
and stuff
oh i could imagine first day one they
break up and it's like i would go home
are we are we still gonna go scuba
diving yeah scuba [ __ ] drown yeah
some guy did that on like a honeymoon he
was scuba diving with his wife and he
like yanked her tank i saw that and then
somebody else was there yeah and took a
picture of it just randomly had a
picture of him yanking swimming away
from her and she's sinking yeah yeah and
they was like a dateline 20 20. i saw
him i saw him tinder saw one recently of
a guy took he apparently took a photo of
his it was girl on the cliff he was like
nah let's go for a hike and then you see
that right
it's not good and then apparently
someone said because they saw like a bit
of a scuffle so he was like take a photo
he took a photo of her went over to she
gave her a good shove yeah down the
mountain and his defenses his defense
was going to be i took a picture then
she fell she slipped but he took a
picture and walked up and then tried to
talk but there were some hikers or
something they said like it didn't look
right yeah yeah it wasn't ending up
that's also what happens dudes throw
their throw their wives off [ __ ]
cruise ships all the time yeah
they just awesome i don't get it why
kill somebody you got heat coming just
breaking international waters that's the
best place to do it
i just listen it's not i get it i get it
i i get it of course i get it but you
can't actually do it just of course yeah
it's one of those things he actually did
it
it's like goodwill hunting when you show
up and your friend is gone yeah it's
like it's just something you mentioned
you dream of
you know every day i wish you
every day i wish to throw you off a
[ __ ] cruise ship lady
that's the best part of my day jerry had
the balls to do it
oh man jesus [ __ ] christ guys all
right so yeah as you know um i'm sorry
no please please please please please
please as you know when you sign up for
the paper
uh we will answer your garbage question
on air with a guest or with a family
episode of me and folks just the best
way to do it because we have so many
[ __ ] submissions and we're working
through the backlog we're almost through
it to be honest with you good stuff um
so here we go let's see uh this is this
brings up vacations and stuff this is
from brian first time question when
staying at a resort is it garbage to
bring your own beer down to the pool and
not order from the bar what's the beer i
can't
depends i got heavy ipas over there
what's happening yeah you bring some
good lights that's very trashy yeah i
think i don't know
rolling with a cooler is a tough look
100 it's [ __ ] garbage you can't do
that i just look at that from a server's
point of view it's like that's his
section
can't have people [ __ ] show it it's
like it's like bringing your own food
into a restaurant it clearly says you
got to order from the [ __ ] server
i mean if there's a rule i think it's a
gray i think you can bring your own
beers not if you're just like lounging
beside the pool like you're lounging
you're not in the barrier area you're at
the pool area it's true i think if they
offer if they offer if they offer
alcohol service at the chairs um
yeah you're that's a scumbag move
i don't know all right you're going i'm
gonna go trashy too
because i'll do it yeah yeah well that's
the
the thing is yeah it's not the classiest
move but it's also like a lot of times
then waitresses don't get them timmy as
quick as i need them right especially a
hot day i need some beers if i'm
drinking i'm drinking and i drink them
quick they're still blowing i'm waiting
around on their [ __ ] do you still
blast them off with a 20 or something
just to keep a don't worry about it no
way no get the [ __ ] out of here i'm not
trying to pay them i'm doing their job i
barely tip them i barely tip when they
give me
something are you tight with the tips no
no i'm
stupidly yeah we were blessing the other
night and he was [ __ ] down i knew her
i knew i used to i used to work in a bar
right beside the lady that was serving
us yeah i couldn't
i couldn't i saw him but it's stiffer
you know it was horrible i saw her and i
was like hey so good to see and she
walked away and then i remember i just
realized how much i'm gonna have to tip
i went [ __ ] yeah
there goes the dubskin yeah yeah
gang let's talk about our good friends
over there at ladder if the pandemic has
taught us one thing you want to make
sure that you plan that you prepare for
the future and life insurance is a big
part of that plan especially term
coverage which is actually surprisingly
affordable these days and the folks you
want to turn to is the good people at
ladder hippie straighten them out yeah
guys uh ladder is 100 digital there's no
doctors no needles no paperwork none of
the hot none of the hassle uh when you
apply for three million in coverage or
less nice three million there you go
what are we doing here uh do you just
need a few minutes on the phone or a
laptop to apply ladder smart algorithms
work in real time so you'll find out
instantly if you're approved there's no
long wait or you know back and forth
approval process it's easy peasy if you
prefer to if you do prefer to talk to a
person their team of licensed agents
doesn't uh work on commissions so
they'll help you and not try to upsell
you you know what i mean they'll get you
the right thing this i got i got patty
on it yeah i know leave a little
something for uncle hank you know what i
mean there's also no hidden fees you can
cancel any time get a
full refund if you change your mind in
the first 30 days i mean who is doing
that nobody ladder policies are issued
by insurers with long proven history of
paying claims and the rated a and a plus
by am best nice finally some life
insurance costs uh finally since life
insurance costs more as you age now's
the time to cross it off your list 100
uh guys so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today and see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage go check
it out stamps.com kippy stamps.com
stamps.com
what do you know about them because over
here around this joint we love them big
stamps.com guy big stamps.com family
here at ru garbage we use them for all
the cards there's no fuss there's no
mess there's no waiting in the line at
the post office they send you everything
that you need you're moving it
out the door in two seconds fantastic
stamps.com yeah uh if you're still
paying full price and you're still
waiting at the post office you're
screwing up that's what i'm telling you
stamps.com you don't have to do that
anymore you can mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer all
you need is a little bit of internet the
printer
that's it but i'm sure they have a
computer i'm sure they have high prices
for ups and for usps right let me uh let
me think no what it's up to forty
percent off post office rates and then
get this that's bonkos up to 66 off ups
shipping rates i mean what are we doing
taking brown for a ride
[Laughter]
with stamps.com
uh is a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters it's a
no-brainer saving you time and money no
wonder
it's nearly 1 million small businesses
have already choose stamps.com such as
us today's today's all over stamps you
gotta love people who support small
businesses and stamps.com does that
better than almost anybody yeah uh guys
there's no risk with our promo code
garbage i got a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale they sent me
the package you set it up it's easy
peasy what are we doing uh just go to
stamp.stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in garbage
you know it you'll love it that's
stamps.com promo code garbage stamps.com
never go to the post office again kippy
how about our good pals over there at
bespoke post bespoke post my fave let me
ask you a question do you like cool
stuff love cool stuff well you got to
get into the box of awesome that they
have over there at bespoke post summer's
time everybody's out want to do cool
stuff the fall's coming you want to have
stuff you need grilling things you need
uh uh self-care stuff
anything travel whatever you got to get
on this bespoke post box of awesome
unbelievable value unbelievable quality
kippy straighten them out uh yeah they
sent they sent us a box we got a bunch
of cool stuff we got uh a cool like uh a
cool knife we got i got an awesome uh
duffel bag that i take on a road with me
when i'm traveling it's good stuff uh
also got a hammock i got the hammer we
got a club foley we got a blanket treat
a treat
it's i it's everything they say is top
notch it's cool guy stuff if you're
trying to be if you're trying to up your
game it's cool guys stuff so get
involved to get started go to box of
awesome.com take the quick quiz the
answers are help them pick the best box
of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month um so you can choose
from a bunch of different categories
it's free to sign up skip a month at any
time you can cancel at any time each box
only costs 45 beans and has over 70
dollars worth of gear inside crazy
you're losing cool guys stuff cool guy
stuff wanna be cool get a box of awesome
and it doesn't guarantee it doesn't stop
there big man you get up to 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com and enter the promo
code garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome.com promo code garbage 20 off
your first box now back to the show
what about in ireland though we don't
tip at all in ireland no there's no most
of europe no we we tip taxi drivers for
some reason
and then we do tip waitresses and stuff
you'll never tip out the bar and you
you troll but it's change yeah if you
order a drink and it's 560 you let them
keep the change that's it
especially if they do that if they bring
it to you like there's a there's a
waitress it's not really righteous it's
more like a you just got to go there to
understand it's like a is that because
they're getting paid they're getting
bigger they're getting higher wages yeah
yeah they're saying like 15 an hour
it's not in the culture yeah but it's
funny is irish people move here they
don't tip originally because they don't
realize but then as soon as they realize
that they tip way too much yeah because
we have a there's a real stigma in
ireland to be cheap really huge stigma
if you're cheap they oh it's so but
all the time people just insult you like
yo you're a cheap [ __ ] yeah really my
wife uh is is german her mom came and
then she we went out to dinner and she
they tipped the same thing but like you
know a couple of bucks on like a dinner
yeah and
she didn't leave enough and i was like
[ __ ] i gotta because she didn't know i
was like i gotta say something and i'm
like i was like hey babe she's gotta
leave like 20 bucks and she's leaving
like i don't know whatever it was i
don't know that's for you it was like a
96 dollar meal and she goes get this
here's 100. yeah something just because
in her that's what that's what they do
and she goes
she was like i was like oh and she's
like no i'm like we have to pay her more
she's like she just was having trouble
like i don't understand why i have to
give her this person twenty dollars yeah
and i was like well they only really
make like 250 and at 2 and 50 cents an
hour and she was like what
i was like yeah she's like that's in
pots she's like that's a league i'm like
no that's what they get paid they work
primarily american baby and then she was
like oh here's like another [ __ ] 50
bucks 50.
whatever she went heavy [ __ ] handed
they just don't know when you come here
that you're only making two dollars that
you're living solely off tips can i say
this sure you're still going out to
dinner with your wife and her mother and
and she and the mom's paying it was like
a treat
and this was last the euro yeah this
the euro stretches over here yeah it
does it's better than better than the
dollar yeah not for long baby
man [ __ ] petey the patriot over here
jesus christ
meanwhile he's wearing spanx all right
ladies and gentlemen no i'm not yes it's
a girdle
and it's prescribed it's medical that
that makes it better a girder maybe yeah
it's got [ __ ] prescription clothes on
i gotta trestle
holding me up
all right let's see here um
this was from laura b ever purchased
anything from sky mall
no no what is that sky mall's the
magazine in the back of the oh i'm here
on a ship how the [ __ ] did you get here
i haven't i haven't purchased and from
that since like the 90s but you do you
have yeah in the 90s that was like it
was like in like it was like a danger
they had like plain replicas or
something back in the day and you could
only get them on planes wait you were
buying models
they have these like uh replica planes
that would like they're just like
ornaments but you could only get them on
on board a plane you were playing with
commercial airliners not like a fighter
jet that's what you'd
yeah he was playing baggage handler
yeah i don't get that like and you
wouldn't even play with them they're
just going yeah it's like it was like
the look truck it was like a replica
it's not it's not like pretty true it's
not like you and your room room blocks
or whatever you want to [ __ ] play
you and your plate or whatever
just making spaghetti and eating it yeah
so scott but what else
would you buy from that magazine well
like now i
i get my aftershave or something no
that's great that's crazy no maybe it's
they have like electronics or like yeah
it's like a cheap brook stone yeah like
trout it's like [ __ ] that you can really
only buy that you can buy like luggage
or you know yeah i've never [ __ ] i
thought it was rich i thought it was
rich people [ __ ] the whole time wow that
magazine's trash in my head i'm like you
got money to spy [ __ ] while you're
flying that's nuts you don't buy it
there like from the from the flight
attendant you know they don't have their
[ __ ] on the plane do they no but you
place the order i think
which it's crazy i don't [ __ ] i
genuinely don't know i tell you what man
the more i fly the more trashy i realize
that it is them coming down the aisle
we've talked about this and hitting you
up for a [ __ ] credit card
after you [ __ ] land is real [ __ ]
trashy
yeah that's garbage yeah yeah yeah
giving you 60 000 miles this and that
which i've i've said i've signed up for
a delta card because it gave me like 50
000 miles or whatever i tried once and
got denied that's why you're [ __ ] mad
on the plane
what's your friend of everyone yeah i'm
sorry sir you've been denied
seat 45b has been denied the seatbelt
extender seat 45 b and c has been denied
and a little bit of d
how about a couple bags of jesus huh
denied again uh what is your credit
limit do you have good credit yeah i
just checked what is it we asked we talk
about ours i don't know it's not
whatever the top one is it's the second
one probably very good very very good so
in the seven
yeah seven something what about your uh
what are they they said the reason i
don't have more is because you don't
have enough credit i haven't been here
long enough
but also technically i would argue the
reason it's not less is because i
haven't been here
[Laughter]
digging myself out i think i'm good i'm
like in the good i'm like yeah i think
i'm like 675 or something like that
what's the how many credit cards do you
have
two you have two card was one of
american express um no never no no
actually i think i only have one now i
got rid of one i think and what's the
limit on it
the one that i have now yeah 12.
i didn't even ask for that i just
checked my bank one day and it was just
12 grand available i was like what and i
was like
i think it's at like
500 right now and i'm like that's crazy
i'm not 500 that's all you have on it
yeah i wipe that off that's pretty good
clean it up every month yeah i've i've
gone to places where it's been tough
where i'm like six seven k in the hole
and then it's like such a horrible to
dig yourself out it's like sweating now
what you get out though is just like i
did it
yeah just be back in two months there
should be some sort of like instagram
posts i should be able to make you know
like a medal congratulations so you got
11 5 to play with right now i i
that's where they get you see this we
don't have credit really in ireland
really we do but it's not like you guys
you guys are
there's an industry it's it it's it's
predatory drug addiction it's like hey
here's a here's a little bit of free
crack you know the next thing you know
then you're throwing your life away
here's a little bit of free free money i
guess no such thing next thing you know
you're blowing somebody at td bank
i uh ours are bad you just got bumped up
to a thousand thousand but i keep it at
five i [ __ ] up the first month that
they bumped me up and jacked it all the
way up to a thousand and it drops your
credit and but that's a tough look at
the end of the month to [ __ ] come up
with that nut so i'm limiting myself to
500. yeah cause 500 at the end of the
month i can pay that because i don't
like it to go over you have to have
everything cleaned up oh i've had it
rolling yeah it's so good will you pay
off the minimum because it's like
they're like you owe his money he's like
you only have to give us 50 and i'm like
yeah i'm only going to give you 50 and
then next time i was like six months
later i'm like
i'm [ __ ] yeah wacky over the head with
surcharges and interest they say always
pay at least even if it's like five
dollars over just never pay the minimum
like if it's 50 pay 50 my credit card
cycle and this might be the trash way to
do it but i'm i've never
been taught how to do it what i would do
is like i'd get to like four thousand
dollars and spend it and yeah i'd buy
stupid [ __ ] and then i would pay off
tiny bits tiny bits tiny bits and then
just one big lump sum wipe it all out
yeah because i'd work so much and i just
have it all yeah and then i go back up
to 5 000 tiny bit tiny bit tiny bit one
giant lump sum
wipe them out yeah
that's probably the trashiest way to do
it i feel like yeah because meanwhile
even though i owe that money i'm like
just cash in in the
cash underneath the mattress sure yeah
you got cash in hand i'm not giving it
to you the way i see it with credit
cards i don't mind like when i pay the
grand at the end of the month or the 500
of the month i feel like i'm just
transferring the money because i still
like i'm not like really paying a bill i
have that money at my disposable at my
disposal on the card does that make
sense
it's like a game that never catches up
to itself you don't think it's real
money is that what you say exactly
because it's like if i have to pay a
thousand dollar bill at the end of the
month that thousand dollars is gone but
if i pay a thousand dollars on my credit
card boom now i have this this this
piece of plastic that's worth a thousand
dollars so it's the same thing as having
the grand so what's the difference
sure in the last month i'll be dead who
gives a [ __ ] that's the whole the dream
right you die with a lot of debt oh yeah
hell yeah but we talked about absolutely
before who does that go to
i don't care i'm dead yeah sorry
somebody else was probably my wife who
was cheating on me
good luck
push her off a club
should have thrown her off a cruise ship
[Laughter]
some scuba diving lessons on the credit
card
all right let's see
let's uh some of these are from fate we
got a couple heaters from facebook this
one's just funny alex have you ever had
gatorade in a glass with ice
um yeah that was because we would get
the big jugs
like the big
oh you get the big boys yeah and then
you would have to pour that into like a
glass but you can't get them cold you
got to get there they're in the the
regular juice eye yeah yeah yeah it
takes a couple of days from the cool
down to the right temperature sure sure
you a big gatorade guy
yeah oddly actually i drink a lot of
gatorade real do you well you know i
work for a moving company so it's just
all the time clients are like gatorade
gatorade and just grabbing it i don't
know if it does that in more than water
but i drink it as opposed to the
electrolyte it refills that's what they
say but like
you know they could tell me anything
it's just [ __ ] like i'm so beyond stupid
yeah it's just like
it's a little bit of salt mixed in
that's it could be just yeah it could be
just food coloring and it's like yo no
this is yeah this is one this is what
lebron uses yeah yeah you want to be
like lebron what sells you on gatorade
it does have that distinct flavor so
you're like oh yeah it must be good for
you i love it you ever mix gatorade and
vodka no good i've yet no i've got to do
that oh that'll [ __ ] you up it's the
gatorade's too thin man yeah this guy's
got 12 grand on a credit card what are
you talking about he's not mixing
gatorade and vodka vitamin water
vitamin water and rum
powerade and tequila there we go now
we're now we're talking that's a real
drink let me ask you that about the
about the moving how do how do you judge
clients like if
personality looks and talent
and you got all three kids
come on you sho you pull up and they
don't offer you a drink at all are you
going i'm probably getting stiffed or
i'm not getting a great tip no no
there's no there's not really a
correlation between
but it pisses you off a little bit right
i think it's rude probably to not have
waters or something ready for the yeah
for your client now what do you take but
if
if you go up and they say hey would you
like some water and they i'll take a
water yeah but what if they go under the
under the sink with the with the glass
to fill it up i'll probably take that
too i'm not really yeah i don't i'm like
a dog do you prefer a cold they could
dip it in the toilet
trigger i would prefer it yeah
that's a that's a good when you show up
at a move and it's clean like so all the
boxes are like in the middle of the room
or something yeah there's no stuff and
there's a tables and you go this is like
there you go all right sure if it's
clean you go all right we're now we're
dealing with someone who i respect yeah
and they go we've bunch of waters
they're in the fridge help yourself nice
and we're gonna go down the store grab
some gatorades you want that that's
that's it that's great what about lunch
they buy you lunch sometimes they do but
it's usually pizza and we don't usually
have time
doesn't that [ __ ] you up for after
because i know anytime after lunch i'm
done yeah anytime i did anything uh any
blue collar job or anything manual after
lunch i was done
a couple of slices i'm [ __ ] like half
asleep yeah yeah it's tough but at the
same time it's like normally but the
problem is here's the thing is a lot of
people go let's buy them pizza don't
have to tip don't have to tip it yeah
yeah i got you the pizza in the gatorade
who needs the cash
is ass
yeah dummy knows
i would say just have some waters ready
only whatever poland yeah yeah poland
springs
yeah just have a couple of poland
springs some gatorades or whatever you
don't need to give them food
and they should be good what's your
gatorade flavor i go
uh the white
like what what white thirst is it quench
cursed quenching oh [ __ ] i thought that
was only a christmas no that's me yeah
every time i say it too everyone goes
what though i've never even had that no
it's it looks like it's it's called like
white
it's called ejaculate i don't know what
they're giving you
sprinting screaming
are you hurting for a squirt
[Laughter]
yeah my i don't i just that's the one i
think it's called something cherry is it
white cherry oh
maybe white cherry
it's a white one yeah that's white but
i'm the only one who ever says you can
only get those at the grocery store
though listen if you're offered you
better go walking
i'm lifting your tv
i don't care where you get it lady
that's how you keep him out of the house
yeah that's what i can find me a white
shirt what do you guys go for light blue
it depends it depends on light blue
light blue if i'm hungover red red red
if i'm hungover or punch
fruit punch is red yeah classic is great
classic what's kind of yellow yeah the
yellow's classic green that's not yellow
it's green it's lemon lime it's yellow i
think it's green
is it yeah it's first
you guys all might be too young for this
but they used to make gatorade gum what
am i
you know me a long time you have that
over there no probably have gatorade
this guy's bonkers without gatorade
you gotta have some you guys have
lucazade right we have lucasade but
leucocete lucas aide's a different milk
it's just curdled milk you know about
fizzy milk
you never had fizzy milk
you guys
it sounds like a prescription
listen uh put a little lucas here you
know you'll be all right
that'll cure right up clears up poison
ivy as well
listen to me
get some lucozade into you yeah hit the
gym
all pr's what wait what personal records
all pr's personally
how do you spell it lucas it's the same
sort of magic [ __ ] that's in every
sports drink it's sort of just a
marketing ploy
for idiots like us oh that stuff doesn't
look good it looks like cortisone
that stuff cures the cold man i'm
telling you that stuff looks like you
clean toilets without no you haven't
that stuff's crazy
next time i next time i go to one of the
irish stores in queens i'm going to pick
you up some lucas there's an irish store
in queens there's a few of them yeah you
go in and you buy like irish chocolate
and it costs you 18. yeah yeah yeah yeah
for sure um
it makes top athletes go uh 22 percent
longer
i think that you can use it in the
bedroom
[Laughter]
finally break two minutes maybe five
percent bigger uh
wow luke but that was lucas one of those
things it was just it was just like a
regular drink and then but people used
to drink it when they were sick they'd
give it to like sick kids and stuff or
something yeah sure and but then stay
hydrated something like that but then
they they rebranded as a sports drink
but i don't think they did anything i
just did the same [ __ ] they just said
they just said we're sports now and
we're like all right yeah i guess so
yeah pedialyte did that over here they
saw all these kids [ __ ] drinking it
when they were hungover yeah now it's
switched up yeah it was for like bait
like if you were like a baby who was the
hot like a child i thought yeah i
thought it was for like uh chronic
diarrhea or something it's for babies
when they're dehydrated yeah from
diarrhea you [ __ ] out everything and
they yeah that gets like the the levels
back up but then people started drinking
it when they got [ __ ] hungry no it's
they just and then they usually hire
some basketball player to say he uses it
yeah you know yeah that's what he's
doing hydrated i use pedialyte or
lucazade
yeah we're the official podcast of the
olympics
that's funny i'd love an ru garbage
sports drink we should i'd [ __ ] i
want to get a beer so if anybody has a
brewery out there let us know nice we'll
do a a garbage nice ipa there you go
that'd be great a little hazy you know
what i mean hoodie's ipa split profits
we'll push it every episode come on
cody's ipa you like it cody's ipa isn't
bad and cody's ipa stop giving away all
the secrets
uh all right this one's a [ __ ] this
is also from the facebook group gotta
show the facebook group a little love
they're out there doing that guys join
the [ __ ] facebook group i think we're
like 3 000 people in the facebook group
already it's cooking over there this is
from charlie butts
i'm not sure if that's his government
name charlie uh have you ever been
friends with someone that was
homeschooled
no
[ __ ] out of here there was a there was a
couple toby was probably homeschooled
you were homeschooled i have a secret
for all of you nuh-uh you're all friends
with someone who was homeschooled we
knew that he told us that i don't think
i knew that yeah i don't know if you
could call what i did homeschooling i
just didn't go to i don't know if you
can call what we call friends either yes
you just didn't go to middle school
correct so you were off for from sixth
seventh and eighth grade that's correct
can i what age is it what age is it uh
that's like 11 to 13.
so you just didn't go to school were you
working in the factories or something
i'd wake up i'd play some playstation
two little metal gear solid two uh i'd
watch some tv my homies would get off
school i go skate with them my homies
your 11 year old homie
we were out there thugging you know the
homies yeah we're out there just playing
pokemon you know
on the corner yeah doing what homies do
that's bananas have you told us
oh yeah you've told us this before what
did your parents say
what would stop were you supposed to be
schooled i mean those are those are
those are key years you learn like
algebra and long division
out he is not a smart guy what i am the
smartest dumb guy you'll ever meet wait
i don't understand how you got away with
that wouldn't wouldn't they come and
take you away from your parents that's
like neglect north carolina dude don't
give a [ __ ] jesus oh nice but if we get
a next patreon that's crazy
we're gonna [ __ ] billy madison yeah
we're gonna re-roll you back in primary
school wow
that'd be incredible
i like it you're getting [ __ ]
watching blockers [ __ ] ps102 over
there
too yeah
you could use it i could i wonder how i
would fare what
jeff siblings yeah older brother yeah
what did he do he was a boarding school
man that's you guys that's like the
opposite of yeah
meet in the middle
[Laughter]
go to a regular [ __ ] how about trying to
regular school it was like all right one
of you is gets to go to boarding school
but unfortunately that's expensive so
toby you're staying here if one he
doesn't have to go to school the other
one has to go all the time
the other one has to live there
rock paper scissors were your parents
strict about your grades growing up no
were you a good student and no
no i was not
no i was i was good early on and then it
just slowly it used to be like oh
gets his work done
very funny sure he just loved me you
know and then it became like a little
bit disobedient and then it just became
like you can't come here anymore really
wait you were you got tossed yeah i got
tossed did you talk about this what no
that
out of high school yeah yeah high school
yeah so did you gonna go to college did
you yeah i did yeah
what's that adversity
sorry what's that a challenge
i've said i wanted a set of choices this
guy's bonkers
head button the dean tell me how did you
get into [ __ ] college without a
degree no did you get like a equivalent
i got transferred in high schools so
they the the principal kind of brought
my parents and they didn't officially
suspend me but they're just like you
can't come back here during the summer
what were you doing what'd you do i was
just i don't know i wasn't even that bad
i don't think i just did but tell
teachers that's all [ __ ] you exactly
i know you as an adult no i was not like
you're a real rabble rouser i wasn't
like violent or anything i didn't beat
anybody up i would just like show up and
they were like where's your homework and
i'd be like i don't believe in homework
man oh yeah i [ __ ] toss you too
making like 30 [ __ ] pounds a month
they were making good money and teachers
okay
you overpaid
but i would be kind of like just like
but listen best case scenario
did you do well in school and they'd be
like yeah i was like yeah but then i'll
just end up like you and you're a loser
and then they're like all right you
can't be in class like this i'm like i
don't want to be in this class
i was born to perform
i'm an artist i'm moving to new york i'm
going to be a star i'll tell you you
start dancing around like billy elliot
yeah they're like you're a dream
material you're a dreamer so how did you
get into university and just two grades
i know what they call it wow look at you
so they so i went to a different school
then private school which was the last
year wow so they kind of they didn't
officially they said like you can't come
back yeah we're not we're yeah we're not
they gave me the option to leave rather
than yeah yeah yeah like a gentleman
yeah exactly can you get the hammer or
you can leave yeah so then i went to a
private school for the final year that
started got the grades went into college
nice never never even put that on a
resume parents pissed that they had to
pay for a private school uh
no
maybe
i don't know
never asked take that as a year is it
expensive or like pricey enough yeah
uniform
no uniform no in the private no that
it's the opposite in ireland it's really
uniform if you're public if you're
private wear whatever you want it's cool
we don't believe in religion hey
wow do you have to dress up like harry
potter in elementary school do you wear
like those suits
i did have a wand
but that was personal no that was more
like a coella deville cigarette
i did have a jacket made out of red
i did have an elf with me
he was just a small kid
and yeah no we had we had uniforms that
we wore trousers
uh sweater sweater with the collar shirt
yeah yeah nice real irish we were irish
i wore that too in catholic school when
i was a kid i like the uniform be honest
with you clip-on tie nice sweater
slip-on
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was
of course i could tie my own tie can you
still can you still not no yeah of
course i can now i don't think you can
oh wait when you were a little high wait
you've deflected that real quick i can
tie a tie hundred percent no
right now no way give me a title
it's the thing you got to learn young
it's like french or something i know
no way i know it's now you can't like
french or something [ __ ] there's a
youtube video to teach you how to do it
in 45 seconds i don't believe that's
like french or anal you gotta learn
young
speaking of catholic school
no you you said that you wore the
uniform in public school yeah so you had
to have it when you were young i was a
kid yeah from early early i learned how
to as soon as i learned how to tie my
laces i tied the tie and then that was
it oh we didn't learn that young took my
dad a couple years to figure it out you
got the dad
yeah my dad
tai yeah he didn't know who taught you
guy wawa what do you mean who teaches
you hi wait it taught your dad a couple
years had to figure out how to tie a tie
oh it took my dad a couple years to
teach me how to tie a tie yeah well you
i mean you you got a grade you want a
curve
there was a technique you could do where
you can open it but not all the way you
hook it of course but then that but you
you can tell you can tell it's a little
weathered yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
banged up
it's like it's like cody's gift
the plate's broken there you go that's
it i i i would put a hundred dollars
right now that you can tie i'm telling
you i can't get me give me something
that's that long i'll tie it for you
right now get your belt yeah i don't
have a belt
i have a drawstring
um next time we hang out we got anything
in here toby no i don't think so no i
mean why would we have a tie in here i
don't know uh this might be too irish
inside baseball but have you ever worked
on a bog
no i have not no the [ __ ] is a bog it's
like a farmer's it's like like a
cranberry bog
that's all i know it's like water right
no
okay it's like it's like dry mud that's
it's like dry soil that you uh
burn you you it dries out in the summer
and then you cut it into logs and then
you can burn it for fuel
that is inside irish yeah jesus is like
the most garbage irish job you could
have is it no it's i don't think it's
garbage it's just farmer stuff farmers
are like the sneaky millionaires i think
that's international too where it's like
you could meet a farmer and he's like
some [ __ ] hillbilly yeah toothless and
then he's like uh yeah bort millions but
he has like just chicken [ __ ] on his
hands and
yeah
mud on his forehead but yeah irish
farmers anyway they're like
wrecked they're just like wild monkeys
and but yet they're worth millions of
dollars really able to show up and
they're just like chewing tobacco and
yeah huh
did let's have a handful of turnips
well he had the pocket full of cake i
have cut bog
as part of a like a school tour where
you like you'd go to visit a farm yeah
like yeah exactly see how it works yeah
but it's like crazy because it's like
we're from the city so they're like this
is a this is the farm yeah you're like
you're looking them at like they're like
zoo animals yes you know yeah like hey
city kids go watch these neanderthals
still cut mud burning apparently is a
thing
they're out here burning dirt
how do you burn dirt i don't know he
explained it pretty well he's like yeah
yeah cut mud and then burn it i was like
dude i don't think i know what mud or
fire is at this point how do you burn
dirt now what i think of it yeah it's
pretty [ __ ]
barbaric
what they're doing out there that's some
trashy [ __ ]
two hours you're burning dirt
it's like an hour and 45 minute drive
from my home is just
wilderness all the farmers are rich
because they got you idiots burning dirt
hey give me give me 20 bucks and burn
this dirt nice yeah holy [ __ ] jesus
that's great um
holy [ __ ] all right let's see um
this is from mary shout out to mary uh
did your parents ever use did your
parents ever
sorry did your parents ever use your
money to help pay for a family vacation
when you were a little kid
did you ever have to chip in at any
point
for my own spending money yes for like
if you wanted to get something it was
had to come out of you i had to save up
money for
what i wanted to buy over there but i
never had to pay towards like a flight
or hotel what was your communion
situation over there did you guys do did
you guys have a holy community oh yeah
big party
yeah yeah a lot of cash a lot of cash
really i was still like the poor kid but
like it was a lot of money what did you
get saying i i can't remember exact
figures ballpark i remember wait so
do you say communion or confirmation
communion communion so communion we were
still i was still dealing in pounds
which was the old money
old money i [ __ ] that's blood money
no no no that was the island before we
changed to the eu in 2000 yeah we had
pounds and i think i was like 260 pounds
or something like that that's right
which was like wild but like for a kid
that age but i'm sure i didn't
people always bought like good stuff i
don't remember buying anything like good
i remember just not having it yeah let
me ask you this my mom i might have
bought a playstation game yeah yeah yeah
you remember she like i got a hundred
bucks i think and i bought a uh
calculator watch
i got a hundred bucks of the money and i
got a calculator watch at clover shout
out to oh she took a cut she took and
then she took the rest oh i'll put this
in the bank and then i thought it was in
a bank until i was like 16.
hey let me use that money she's like
that's been [ __ ] cool
that's rooted in catholicism yeah you
gotta pay point points on the fig oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta
kick it i gotta let there be you gotta
kick it up because you're always ain't
free all right you don't see it no no i
didn't see it at all yeah my mom took
the whole thing the whole thing the
whole thing wow it was like 250. patty i
know you got it
[Laughter]
you got 900
900 people yeah yeah my family my
family's huge so it was like nice it was
like
25 bucks for them and we used 300 people
were you dressed up like [ __ ]
groomsmen too yeah it was a big deal all
in white white
yeah i think communion is white right in
vegas
what the [ __ ] am i thinking of i don't
know i think this is when you were in
the commodores i don't know what you're
talking about
yeah what were you singing in the four
seasons i come back to the microphone
um no i don't mind isn't it right here
the photo right yeah no there was one i
thought we brought it in it is me i do
have like a suit i look like [ __ ] a
young chubby tony soprano wow
you found it oh there's a tumble i think
that might be my niece or is that it let
me see here wow this is a family book no
that's not my that's my holy communion
banged up for 12 years
he's our little eight-year-old
you don't know what's going on yeah it's
probably hungover
if i had to guess
oh that's funny as [ __ ] yeah that's what
we would do we would dress up
in like shoots yeah put on a [ __ ]
suit or a purse
the girls would wear like white dresses
girls would wear a white dress it's a
traditional irish comedian so you have
to fight a dog right
you have to fight the gypsies
down at the town square
we we don't joke about the gypsies
you reached my line
[Laughter]
very very few have been here
congratulations you're on the top of the
mountain wait tell me
no he's gonna steal my soul wait why no
joking about the gypsies
hey homeschooler keep it quiet
no we love them
[Laughter]
really yeah it's not a big no-no
this is for superstitious purposes
i'm not gypsy i'm not the jiffy no i
know you're not no no it's just it just
doesn't go it just doesn't go away
wait they wouldn't be fans of a joke
they wouldn't or you were irish
of course not yeah i would never [ __ ]
make fun of a gypsy in front of a gypsy
they're thousands of miles away
these posers are still in ireland these
idiots don't have the internet yet
wait hold on if you were do you guys
tease gypsies
not to their face what are you doing
what do you do
nervous are you nuts
wait is this like bad
it's like going up to a big giant black
guy or something and making fun of him
that's crazy okay but i just i just want
to understand are we we don't we're not
going to make fun of them i love all
gypsies of course shout out travis and
they don't call me chips
travelers travelers yes of course
they're members of the traveling
community yes um and they have my mom
yeah let's just restart this episode
we're picking up from the credit credit
score not a fact listen but wait so what
they'll just sandra i'm sorry i'm sorry
all right so they're just uh so like if
somebody were if they were walking down
the street and someone was said
something rude or made fun of them or
something what if that's a fight or that
you will they will end you really
absolutely really they're a rough and
tumble bunch yeah they're like they're
like tyson fury the heavyweight champion
shout out to the [ __ ] i love tyson
gypsy kings
i love the [ __ ] out of him dude yeah um
yeah his feet yeah the the gypsy king
they are just they're just rough uh
culturally rough and and tough and it's
where i'm from
which was like i guess it was like upper
lower class if that makes it any sense
we were poor but we weren't like the
poorest it's garbage but i love it upper
upper level
i think they call that middle class and
a lot of
we
them
i wish we were just we didn't have mud
money okay guys
i don't want to think i was some big mud
salesman
not a bog tycoon or anything like that
a mud warrior
that's so funny bog tycoon yeah but but
the the the the tough kids
from my neighborhood that would like
beat me up or beat me and my friends up
and if you saw them you're like oh
here's [ __ ] yeah here's rocco you know
and you know rocco i know alright i know
was that his government name or is that
a name that was he was rocco the third
line
i knew a rocko too and i was just like
that's insane that that's your name yeah
but then the truth rocco got hit by his
dad but it was always like like he you
know the toughest in all of the
neighborhoods and the toughest kids from
all the neighborhoods would fight each
other and then like the travelers would
choke and just [ __ ] humiliate rock
really
just run
[Laughter]
tough kid tough community they've had it
they've had it hard and uh you know it
just doesn't end well when you make fun
of them now
yeah no i don't i don't uh we're another
traveling community out there we are not
making fun of you
we love it these right these guys
definitely they were
i always have your back
shout out to the [ __ ] gypsy
king shout out to the shout out
dude do you know he's nervous because he
looked at nine characters i know he
doesn't know let's go i'm like which one
is me
[Laughter]
zoom in on me that's crazy the
mcdonald's big fan of you guys the
mcdonald's uh i thought it was because
of a superstition or something like that
like a black cat
don't make it like they'll put a hex on
you or something yeah don't walk under a
ladder yeah yeah they'll just punch you
in the face don't make fun of me
i think oh
i don't think i don't think there are
anything in fisticuffs okay they'll mess
you up uh then who were the my next
question would be because i who who are
the
like the beggars
that are out in the streets there's like
a system of beggars and that's like
roman gypsies yeah and that is fair game
yeah okay
those were the gypsies i was originally
talking those [ __ ] can't fight for
[ __ ]
he's about to paint his masterpiece
holy [ __ ] those are the gypsies i'm
talking about yeah
there's this system of
i guess roman r whether roman roman
gypsies roman gypsies and they're like
romanians like roman no romanian gypsies
romanian and they're they're beggars on
the street vegas and there's like they
funnel all the money up right as far as
i'm aware does it again like everything
sure sure does the kick ups there's a
kick up system to like but like there
was also this story of like
them getting they give women babies to
get more money so like a woman will be
like holding a baby to get more money
it's like hobo cutco yes it's a p it's a
hobo pyramid this was in slumdog
millionaires
where they took the eye out yeah they
burned the kid's eye yeah similar thing
eh i guess but we we didn't really get
romanian gypsies until like
in the mid-2000s really yeah
and they would like
yeah i don't know i guess
i can't really talk about this but i
guess romania has a
it's like a real culture of like begging
i guess okay yeah there's like a lot of
homeless begging and that's like your
job and
you know i don't know yeah i really i've
never to be honest i've never like sat
down i've been like yeah
yeah tell me where you come from it's
always just it's always just me putting
up my window going
[Music]
so where are you from originally
yeah yeah yeah
but it turns out now recently that they
found true 23 and me the remaining
gypsies and the irish gypsies are
actually the original travelers the
irish irish irish travelers are from
thank you
they're from the same
i guess area maybe or originally before
they spread out before they spread out
but they lost they they have a lot in
common
but they lost like a lot of it and now
it turns out that
because they don't they don't they they
don't read or write traditionally in the
culture so they never had like a history
did you all these fake stories about
coming from dragons and [ __ ] and then it
turns out they tested it and turns out
they are they are related kind of yeah
that's what i read sick so there's not a
lot of reason there's not it's
traditionally not
taught to read and write in there and
the travelers
it's kind of nuts because i can talk
about this all day but like in ireland
you'll have all your like
neighborhoods and then you just have one
neighborhood which is a park and then
it's full of caravans where they just
live yeah and then they just do their
own thing traditionally they had their
own schooling their own traditions and
they would travel from ireland to
england all the time and back in the day
they used to have like a horse and
carriage and then it became more like
caravans and they always fought and they
were they just made ends meet they're
kind of just like they're kind of just
off the grid yeah they were there and
then well outside of society a little
bit they're like they're like amish
jocks
kind of like amish jocks yeah yeah yeah
they were off the grid doing their own
thing
and
you know not to be trusted but
this got me nervous listen this has to
be true this is going on patreon by the
way listen
i don't think there's any gypsies there
if they don't want to flush them out if
there's good land they'll show up
[Laughter]
column's opinions do not reflect that of
to the llc kevin ryan or henry foley i
stand with the gypsy king absolutely um
but uh because there was that show i
don't know how real it was but to the
two factions fighting
oh you're thinking knuckle you're
thinking of big fat gypsy weddings yes
yes which i used to watch big fat gypsy
wedding and they would try to get
married and they weren't they would lie
they would hide the fact that they were
gypsies like the venue or like the
caterer or the dj because they didn't
want to work with them so they would
hide and then they would show off the
day of and the place was like no no no
it was like always a [ __ ] it's still
still to this day party like they would
they would [ __ ] rage party and then
like you know smash up against fashion
business owners
yeah yeah they get a little rowdy you
know yeah they get a little bit on the
fringe of these guys yeah i love that
[ __ ] show
was there an american version of the
show or was it nothing it was the
english version of my big fan this one
was weird too because it it it was the
first one to let cameras inside the
culture it's like and it was very
secretive so even the people that were
on that show the gypsies they started
getting shown shunned it from the actual
because they were given to them giving
away the secrets and all that stuff yeah
yeah go watch big fat gypsy wedding it's
just crazy yeah no it's like captain
you're like you're watching [ __ ] where
you're like what in the [ __ ] that thing
knuckles that that scared me knuckles
like where i'm from they they grew up in
they were from kulak and i'm just like
it was like two groups that didn't like
each other and they just kept they would
put up their best guy to fight yeah they
yes yes just bare knuckle boxing just oh
and they put their houses and then the
two they i think they called them clans
for some reason but the two families
would go up and they would just be bare
knuckle boxing and they would put down
a hundred two hundred thousand dollars
cash and they would just punch each
other until someone quits that's the
rules dude dudes i would
[ __ ] with beyond tough yeah
and that's why we don't say much
[Laughter]
big fan of the of the traveler i am too
yeah yeah yeah 100. this is not getting
released
i don't i don't think you said that in
wrong i'm kidding
you also make it seem like they're going
to find us or something you don't know
what the [ __ ] man i like they're like
it's the irish they're nomads
yeah when i first brought up the topic
of gypsies i was talking about the
romanian gypsies
i didn't think of the travelers i was
thinking about the the people okay but
we all agree that kevin did bring it up
absolutely right you should see what he
says off-camera guys because he's been
absolutely i
know shout out to [ __ ] tyson fury
you keep going back to that that ain't
gonna save your life i love it shout out
to travelers come on shout outs
love the travel channel i love it all
that's amazing
i love the travel channel my insurance
companies travelers
[Music]
i'm good i'm trying to cup dude i was uh
i was just in germany and then the
dominican republic so i'm like [ __ ]
this is i've gone maybe 36 hours without
booze and i'm like
dying to get back how are they by the
way this is great this is really really
yeah we got that from a listener on the
road appreciate it yeah yeah that's
where he works wow mixed breed brewing
can we give him a shout out tell him to
send me some beers yeah
send them out mixed breed mixed breed
brewing i think i get connecticut i i
guess some beers are no new york or i
forget where it is
uh
gilderland
center new york okay i get i get i get
beer sent to me all the time do you
remember the time yeah
i'm a big i always talk on the part
about how i [ __ ] i'm a big ipa guy so
now when we go on the road people always
give me like he brought me a four pack
another you know like they'll just be
like hey kippy i have you be like i have
beers for you the ipa four packs are
pretty classy yeah right what do you
think i got nice designs
yeah what's what's that you're drinking
now this is actually a pale ale but it
tastes like an ipa it's called zombie
dust by tree floyd's that's a good beer
zombie does this fire yeah it's it's
gray zombie does three floyds has uh
it's really popular in chicago they'll
only let you buy one six pack at a time
at the store
really
sounds like some [ __ ] nerd [ __ ] yeah
no [ __ ] someone sent me um ipas like a
week or two ago
but they were like
the worst things i've ever tasted in my
life really i mean i mean beyond
it was like fear factor style there was
one called buffalo wangs it tasted like
um
buffalo sauce have you ever had an alert
well have you ever had malort the lord
or malort never heard of it no it was
it's a [ __ ] liquor should we do this
you're not going to make me drink
something don't yeah it's not good it's
okay i'll try it i'll try it like if we
can if you you're backing him into a
corner i'm not trying he's irish she's
not going to take it he's not going to
not take care of it i'll do it come on
is it chicago tradition you can only eat
in chicago that's great keep it there
it's horrible
send you back with it
yeah it's like it tastes like
potpourri and poison just let him taste
it if you're making him go don't put it
in my head yeah but this guy sent me
that and then he sent me what else that
he sent me um
it was something called ranch dress
dressing tastes like ranch dress the
beer the beer oh
no it was it was so bad and i felt bad
because i drank it live on a podcast i
was like this is the worst thing yeah
and i felt so nice because i was like
and it was from his brewery that he
worked in he was like you're gonna love
this there's like nothing there's not a
human alive that would yeah would you
would like that yeah he's a carl
jefferson company chicago illinois all
right let me get it let me get a little
lord
kali tease all right first shot of
lamort lamorte
actually
it's not nice it's a grower
it's a tough look
if it's bothering you now you're giving
me the shivers but
squished it around that's hardcore
[Laughter]
it's like a gobstopper it's just
yeah
take a sip of your beer dude
it makes it worse it's not fun it's not
enjoyable no i don't understand
it's not good
um but we love it i got i got
six shivers like six
you can do like one or two and you go
alright yeah
again
why did and people drank that for like
it's like a baby people enjoy it yeah
it's like every bar you go to has a
chicago handshake it's like five bucks
for a beer and a shot of alert i'll pay
you
a hundred dollars
to never bring that up yeah [ __ ]
horrible what do you think it tastes
like
feet i can't even like febreze or
something
this guy gave me glee
that's crazy well thank you for doing
that well thank you thank you for your
hospitality
give me my [ __ ] plate back
a smasher like a greek wedding
oh all right good stuff uh sometimes all
right let's uh let's run through a
couple of more here this one's from sean
on patreon ever replace the dead
batteries in your remote with the
batteries from the smoke detector
[Music]
that's dancing with the devil wait smoke
detector is nine volt if you got
anything other than a nine volt in your
smoke detector that's [ __ ] trash if
you got triple a's in your smoke
double a's
either way it's got to be a nine volt so
i wouldn't take it from there take it
from remote to remote though 100 percent
that dvd player doesn't need [ __ ]
yeah you know what i'm never using that
yeah yeah i can't remember ever you it
is all nine volt i think you yeah you
kind of loophole in this oh [ __ ] maybe
camping it can't be from the smoke
detector now what i'm saying is i'm not
saying this guy doesn't have a smoke
detector with double or triple a's but
that's [ __ ] trash but i do take the
batteries out of smoke detectors if it
goes off once oh
this is statistically i'm not going to
need this propaganda from big fire
department
big fire that thing starts beeping it's
a [ __ ] pain in the ass yeah and you
got to get the chair out [ __ ] gloves
my anxiety is just cooking through it
too it's like it just builds and builds
and you're probably stressed because
you're cooking something that is like
super smoky then yeah yeah yeah
you're using the broiler so it's like
you've got four minutes yes and four
minutes one second you're [ __ ] you're
on the clock you're on yeah yeah so
you're driving me you're on the chair
and she's like what can i just help you
like no get the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ours is so strong that the shower will
set it off oh wow steam in the shower oh
cause like lack of oxygen yeah yeah just
just the the steam coming out of the
shower i like to take a hot one [ __ ]
that's crazy sets it off that's [ __ ]
nuts just let's be honest
you know get rid of them
at least i mean one have one in the
kitchen or the bedroom or whatever i got
one in the bedroom one in the kitchen
and one in the office i quit bragging i
mean they're [ __ ] smoke
i actually got three of them actually
yeah
i think i know who brags about smoking
yeah my smoke detector's got smoke
detectors
this one's gold-plated this one spins
this one's carbon monoxide and smoke huh
have you guys ever been in a fire no yes
oh i knew it ah
we had an apartment on second avenue it
was a three-floor walk-up each unit had
a washer and dryer fully knocked over a
lantern burned down chicago
what was her name mrs o'leary it's like
bessie the bit the cow
that's that was
that's what homeschooling gets you
that's why it went over these idiots
head i got it i got it i mean i i didn't
know the origin i knew it was the that's
the extent of toby's world history
though that's all we learned in three
years all right um
no so we had uh
we had three apartments stacked on one
another washer and dryer was [ __ ]
awesome girls lived upstairs their dryer
caught on fire
[ __ ] huge [ __ ] things she comes
running down in a towel screaming
[ __ ]
smoking toe screaming [ __ ] the place
is on fire the place is on fire
[ __ ] her apartment burned up we all
ran outside firemen came put it out that
was hitting on the way
no but you know he's funny she had a cat
oh right do you want me to save your
character
she had a cat and she when she came
downstairs in there for the he goes
she'll save the day she goes my cat's in
there he's like i got this he runs it
comes out comes out with some twinkies
or something
i couldn't find a cat but i got the
meatloaf out of that
are you eating this that's a good
brisket
wow
smokey
figure we can't use the kitchen the rest
of the night you know what i mean
we'll split this up between the guys huh
no so there was a cat upstairs so me and
my brother made an attempt to try to get
in there to get the cat but there was so
much smoke coming out it was like we
were yeah
we never would have made it you tried
yeah we like we ran back upstairs and
you know got to the front door and the
smoke was building out and yeah like
this
wow so we came back down but then when
the firemen got there they went up with
the hoses and stuff but we knew one of
the dudes that was on the truck
and he's like they were up there
fighting over who brought the cat down
yeah they all wanted to look so funny
yeah they were up there fighting that's
like the funniest why the building's on
fire they're fighting over and you guys
couldn't even get in and those guys are
sitting there
they're arguing they're trying to get
laid
you were touching the doorknob like yeah
what are you talking about
yeah there's just ward falling down
they're flipping a coin
[Laughter]
meanwhile the foley boys are out in the
stream
wow they had masks on and hoses we had
nothing yeah it was a three-story
walk-up let's be honest
smoke or no smoke your cat's gone
the cat was fine
the cat survived cat survived did did
the firemen get a date
i couldn't tell you that
cat did the cat did die late
make up the ending the story a little
better no what did matt said i don't
know i said i don't know just say yeah
they fell in love and lived happier
happier ever after the cat did die later
on you sat on it but it was drugs drugs
nice nice
[Laughter]
on the low i've had a couple of bombs on
this one that one just completely no
well i gotta be honest the gypsy thing
flustered me i'm sorry yeah that's my
fault it's okay well you brought up i
know i did not i brought up the romanian
gypsies
uh that was good honestly everything we
said was fine i think now is a good time
to discuss a raise for me
i'm just gonna not make this available
in [ __ ] in the uk we'll be all right
can you do that i don't know that'd be
great
i do i i would also are the travelers a
big podcast listening no absolutely not
no yeah too busy
yeah they're watching us on youtube
right now at [ __ ] con
you're not in my [ __ ] in the bucket
[Laughter]
kevin ryan
you're not in my flight my name's henry
foley i'm henry foley your phlegm on me
mother's willy
i don't know what that meant but it
sounded funny yeah
um all right let's do two more here and
then they wrap it up this one's for uh
this is also from facebook from austin
ever use an electric toothbrush as a
regular toothbrush because it died
and you've never replaced it are you are
you an old-school toothbrush or electric
tube electric
what brand you rocking
i have no one no sonic carol nobody
honestly
you could replace my toothbrush and i
wouldn't even know i don't i there's
toothpaste all over like a burning
candle there would be but i live with my
girl she cleans it up she cleans it up
those things get right yeah they get
they get crazy especially on build up
quickly especially if you put it in the
holder the whole thing that holder
smells like no we you got to watch the
holder every two days or something it's
crazy it's crazy you leave the holder
there you come back the next day there's
like a mushroom hanging out of it it's
crazy it's wild it's it's it's wild how
fast
poor men
is that the word formants ferments
ferments yeah torments yeah life
yeah i've had i've had two i think and
every time like i had to replace the
bristles
and this was before they were like they
jacky on them briskly they jack on the
bristles and i would i would get i would
buy it and buy like a three pack and go
through the bristles and then
i was just like well i'm not order like
i would you know i'd just be like oh let
me just use this old this like
traditional toothbrush and then i just
never [ __ ] ordered it yeah i love it
i'm a big traditional guy
so much better i think that just you
just feel that way because it is that
because it's clean i think yeah it's for
sure i i feel yeah do you floss
sometimes
it's a hard no
[Laughter]
i don't do it all right who's asking
fatty
i no i got a floss because i got like i
used to have braces but i never wore my
retainer so now they're like my teeth
are just banged up again sure you know
what you need to get it's uh i forget
the comp the company but it's glide
and they're like the single picks
and then all these are awesome they go
in it's like orgasmic feel it doesn't
hurt it's like it's not it's like they
slide right in i use the ones they look
like a little harp and then yeah yeah
yeah
get the ones that say glide it's a game
changer okay a game changer i'm going to
do it absolutely absolutely but but i
would do what they said i've just never
i'm too efficient but yeah i would
definitely just absolutely i've done it
100 it stinks
it's tough
those aren't meant to just be used as
regular yeah yeah they're two yeah
they're too small um all right this
one's from ian and then let's wrap it up
here uh have you ever removed your own
stitches
that's if you're doing any sort of
medical procedure from my mouth i have i
think they tend to fall out right yeah
yeah it's a little bit but i've looked
at them yeah i picked out them used my
tongue
it was the weirdest sensation who's
removing their own stitches
john mccann
john wick i bet you the travelers do the
okay change it chase we were out dude we
were so out we were
gone just seem like such tough people
we're on the [ __ ] 95 north we're
going the opposite direction
and then you uh
you just turn this guy on go and do that
yeah but no i've never removed my own
stitches no that's wild my brother took
his cast off i remember that she was you
ricky bobby
scissors yeah in the middle of the night
it was just like i got to get this thing
the [ __ ] off of me it just took it off
you know you're healed if you want to
take it off no i think it was like the
first week jesus yeah right
actually now you say it i had a cast and
then my dad
took it off what yeah like in the
departed he just smashed
why are you already
are you a traveler are you going to stop
doing coke deals with your jerk-off
cousin
he goes who'd you love more me and your
mother
wait why did he take it off nah that was
the whole bit i just brought it up that
was the joke
i don't i just brought it up for that
joke he moves quick
he sets him up and knocks them down real
quick
but now you mean maybe you feel like an
idiot
you're the best the kid's all right
carly t call him terrell everybody the
wizard of oz
what do you what do you want the folks
out there to know you got coming up plug
away fire away um oh i'm i am i'm
recording a crowd work album nice i love
it at the stand in new york city
um october 6th i believe but tickets are
available right now only available on my
patreon patreon forward slash column
tyro okay so you'll get a code there
there's only a few tickets available and
come out check it out i'm i'm making i'm
doing it all myself every single thing i
don't have a single person helping me i
[ __ ] this kid self-made man self-made
man we talk all the time yeah we always
do [ __ ] how to you know because we
you know we nobody fights nobody's
coming to bring you
to the party the body the cavalry is not
coming to save you you gotta learn and
you're you guys um big inspiration to me
i love what you've done you guys have uh
you're growing all the time you've got a
big big future ahead of you thank you
thank you you guys are leading the way
for people like myself and i'm i'm proud
of you guys
we're proud of you hilarious good work
ethic guys if you don't support his
podcast please go check it out it's
absolutely fantastic supporters patreon
he's one of the best one on the phone
i'm gonna go have the two you gonna
guest yeah yeah for sure we're hoping we
just we've had some um scheduling yeah
this guy's on vacation every other week
every time i talk to him he's like yeah
no i'm in tokyo
what no it's 2 a.m okay for that comment
i'm ignoring your call next time
but please come check it out 100 check
out the wizard of pod gang thank you
kippy what do you got for him uh just
always please make sure you rate where
you subscribe itunes youtube uh and
patreon and guys the live shows are
[ __ ] cooking uh
by this point i think uh
we'll have texas philly long island
we're working on new york city and
working on west coast states working on
everywhere so get some [ __ ] tickets
and come and see us gang we love you
we'll see you next week